there's unanimity among physicists of
course we can disagree about whether or
not we should go to 11 dimensional
hyperspace in strength Theory or not but
four-dimensional special relativity is
very well established in fact that's how
we make hydrogen bombs second of all
there is the public human perception of
time and that's where we get into all
these paradoxes because of the fact that
we humans have our own personal
perception of time which does not
necessarily Jive with the physicist
interpretation of time aren't scientists
humans they build their science also on
the basis of their perceptions so why do
we make such a distinction between the
public and the audience and the
scientist